welcome to this video playing Z darken
our Zita comin from Brazil new opponent
having played him before i play my phone
should be four line against a scotch
let's see what he comes up with there
should be three all the capture on c6 on
the main moves and now cam this is also
playable of course so now you know if
you watch my channel you know I have
this weakness Hawkwind each form I'm
going to play it why not the night on b3
is far away and turn maybe I could have
played 95 pre-empting Knight f3 first
but ok it's not a big deal on idea three
I can play Queen age 5 aha didn't didn't
play that interesting I can also play
Bishop g4 on castles first ok I can
castle first this was this idea
so Nyjah for now is just age 30 which
does not lead to anything if I play this
year he cannot really I mean he must
move the Queen if i play 95 now we are
95 night x b 6i think Knight f3 check is
just winning so maybe after 95 and he
has to take the night only five instead
of the bishop night XP 693 should win
what isn't this winning neither 3i I
think takes Bishop takes with
threatening Queen g4 made and I don't
see what he's doing against it okay
check
I don't see a defense to that between
h3g to also
I rookie one no I can play Queen age
three and here i can place a check and
take the rook but i can also play Queen
age three you know Queen edge three
threatening made on g2 bishop f1 cringe
for and mid next movie this is even more
convincing than winning the rook white
resides yes on neat little trickier with
90 x b6 he must take on e5 with the
night here night 65 and then white is
perfectly ok of course here if he takes
only five because this must be okay for
white for sure I mean I have some active
pieces active looking pieces but there's
not much going on really maybe even c4
in this position intending to win the
bishop probably here yeah maybe
something like that this is totally ok
for what should be about equal stockfish
is giving why the slight edge 0.2 I have
possibly have those ideas getting the
Queen back it's not doing much now on h4
yeah this is okay of course but Knight
b6 is made yeah yeah this is maiden made
in something made in 49 a check yeah
quite need yeah this is the the quickest
way to make this is the only check move
from a delaying matters a bit funny um I
could have maybe if you think back here
here maybe should have considered 95
first but it's not really leading to
much you can still play that okay so
this is perfectly okay Bishop g4 maybe
maybe here nobody still can
Knight f3 I mean this is all ok for me
it's not threatening anything I can for
instance if everything else fails I can
always do something like that and the
queen is contributing to the whole thing
I cannot easily grab of course because
of the e far but it's doing something it
harmonizes with the rest of the pieces
yeah nice quick wind thanks for watching